How did we get this far?
Human beings have an immeasurable desire to discover.
To invent.
To build.
Our future depends on us furthering these ideas.
Our responsibility rests on the shoulders of generations to come.
on
But with every new discovery.
There is risk, there is sacrifice, and there are consequences.
this
the
"Be ready for what's coming" "What is coming" "The answers"
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie! So this is going to be the breakdown of the teaser trailer.
So a lot of things different about the film from the original films or even the comic book origin stories. So I will try to explain as we go along.
Generally just think of it as a version of Chronicle if it was done like David Cronenberg's "The Fly" and that actually sounds pretty exciting!
The easy in to this is that it is the Michael Bryan Bendis, Mark Millar origin story from Ultimates. So just read Ultimate Fantastic Four and you should be good to go!
If you're gonna borrow from comic book people, Millar and Bendis are a very safe bet.
In this version of the origin story the characters start  out as teenagers and Reed Richards develops a form of teleportation as a child.
He gets found by a benefactor who inducts them into a program which becomes like the proto-Baxter Building.
It gets into end-zone stuff, so if you are not familiar with the end-zone stuff just read the Ultimate Fantastic Four, just read the first run.
In that comic their first big villain was Mole-Man. But it's like our first step into multiverse so Fantastic Four is getting to multiverse before the Marvel Universe, before the MCU is getting to multiverse.
So we have to give them a high five for that.
So let's just start with the big easter egg that Simon Kinberg was teasing (he's the screenwriter) He's a big man on campus with the X-men films, he works on the X-men films a lot and he also works on Lucasfilm on the Star Wars films.
He is a really cool writer, he said there would be a really big trailer.
Turns out it's this Sue Storm scene
when is looking at all the monitors
If you look at the IP address here it
actually points to Marvel's wiki page for The Nation Of Latveria. So it looks like we will see some Latveria in the movie.
What they're calling the
movie is a contemporary reimagining.
I know everyone also wants to know if this is
going to be connected to the x-men films.
Unofficially it is, officially it stands
on its own.
I think they're slowly getting to the
place where they can do x-men Fantastic
Four crossovers.
So now going back to the beginning if you are unfamiliar with Josh Trank he is
known for doing Chronicle.
Which is actually a pretty fun movie. He also just
signed on to direct one of the Star Wars
spin-off movies.
So he is something a rising star so if
Lucasfilm thought he was good enough to
do Star Wars than
I think it bodes well for this film.
This is just a skyline shot of New York City which is
probably buried underneath snow right now.
Young Reed Richard getting in some into some
scientific trouble.
The bases of their powers isn't going
to be a cosmic radiation cloud,
It is actually going to be
a teleportation experiment so here's
another slight modifications
so the bases that their experiment is
funded by the military
instead of being scientific the US
military is looking for teleportation technology.
Here's our first big shot of Miles Teller
as Mister Fantastic.
If you haven't seen him in Whiplash you
need to see that movie he totally killed it!
Casting him is like a big 180 from
previous iterations the character and
I'm actually really happy with this
change.
Mister Fantastic in the comics, if you read them is very cold, he is a very cold character, very hard to read.
It doesn't always play
well on screen because he kinda comes off as a dick.
He is obviously a very wide eyed scientists
very young in this look is a
a very young version of the characters
but I I'm interested to see what kinda
pathos he brings to the role.
Like I said just watch Whiplash, he has this very
crazy intensity in the movies.
So I'm expecting something like that his
performance.
Kate Mara (Sue Storm) this is actually where we get
our first big easter egg
this IP address down here that I mention.
This is Jamie Bell
as Ben Grimm AKA The Thing. I'd say out of all
the roles he's probably gonna have the
most fun usually it's the villains that
have the most fun
but being being Ben Grimm you get to just be
absolutely crazy.
SMASHY SMASHY! Here's Michael B Jordan as
Johnny Storm.
I know a lot of people were wondering you
know what the relationship between John
and Sue Storm was going to be they'll still
be brother and sister and in Michael B Jordan
is an amazing actor.
So as weird is it might seem that
they're changing the characters
so much, I think it is going to be pretty
interesting. I'm more worried about the
ability the actors then them doing
an exact carbon copy the comic.
This is Dr. Franklin Storm. This is
obviously Johnny Storm's father.
So the characters go through the classic
transformation sequence.
This is gonna probably one of the most things parts of the movie. Watching characters get their powers is probably one of the best things about superhero movies.
Here is our first shot of The Thing. There was some behind the scenes stuff
that leaked earlier but I actually that
these finished effects look pretty
amazing!
So here's our first shot of Johnny Storm as The Human
Torch. If anybody has been watching
The Flash this season this actually kind of
reminds me of the Particle Accelerator
explosion except Metahumans are just
gonna be popping up everywhere.
You have to remember that Marvel is doing The Inhumans, not Fox.
Although it does kind of remind you of a Terragen Bomb. This is a shot of Toby Kebbell.
He is playing the
Victor Von Doom character although they are slightly
changing the character's name is Victor Domashev.
He's gonna be like a a computer hacker.
There's not a whole lot of information
about his character beyond that so I'm
going to wait to talk about him until we
get more official information
so here's a better shot of Human Torch
and Invisible Woman.
And Mister Fantastic about to use his powers.
Obviously they're gonna hold off on those. I'd say out of all of The Fantastic Four's powers
Reed Richards poweres are the weirdest. So I
totally understand why they're gonna
wait to show those off.
Like setting yourself on fire looks
pretty badass, but just like stretching
yourself a lot
is just kinda weird. That's why a lot of
times I think when you see him in the
more recent comics like the New Avengers
comics,
He's busy doing crazy illuminati stuff
and not like stretching himself around
all over the place
If there is any crazy alien that I would like to see them do, like any crazy invading force
It would be The Skrulls
If they did Shi'ar I think I think that would show up in an X-men film not  Fantastic
Four, but I think The Skrulls would totally
work in Fantastic Four.
That's really where the rights flow
from. But lemme know, do you guys want to see them
try to do Shi'ar
with the X-men films and Skrulls with
the Fantastic Four films at some point?
All in all the trailer makes me very hopeful
for the film so, so we'll see!
it's coming in August so we will get at
least three or four more trailers before
then. So we'll see some more footage.
Once we get to the summer like comic-con
they'll probably start promoting the hell out
of the film.
So I'm expecting them to do something
pretty big at comi-con. So once we start
getting some more footage and more
information about the film
I'm gonna be doing more bonus videos for
Fantastic Four the comics
and what's going to be different about
this film. So be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff. So don't forget new
episode to The Flash tonight Pipe Piper is
coming on
and Agents Of S.H.I.E.L.D. There is actually a
reddit AMA going on for Agents Of S.H.I.E.L.D
So I'll post the link in the description.
Right now while you guys wait for that you can click here to learn all about Gorilla Grodd's
origin story in the comics. He'll be coming on The Flash this season.
And you can click here to catch up with what's
going on
in Marvel Phase 3. Thank you so much
for watching so let's all high five and I'll see you guys tonight!